the Elder sisters are a little bit more
traditional the rest of sisters were
born in the U.S and we're the wolf pack
this is nonsense
I have come together again with one
woman charity who I trust Abdullah who
had 100 donation policy we are now
raising funds to build houses for those
who have been homeless due to natural
disasters in Afghanistan Syria and
Pakistan please donate whatever you can
may Allah build you guys at home for
helping and enabling them to have a
house
so this video was sent to me by
Instagram people send me videos and like
have you seen this Etc and yeah I got my
wife to watch this I tried to watch some
parts but obviously they dressed up very
very inappropriately usually you know I
just come to the screen and just you
know just head soccer and see the head
but um they just kicked off fake all
that kind of stuff but anyways that's
not the point of this video the point of
this video is very simple that people
somebody made a video and he was very
upset and it was like look how they're
mocking Etc and there's some truths that
he spoke but the point was what was that
he was claiming that now that they're
trying to you know at one video they're
praying and in the next one they're
clubbing Etc and I thought we need to
touch up on this point because a lot of
people have this massive misconception
which I'm going to come to now these are
girls who are Afghani they are
originally Afghani and they claim that
in the 80s the family came down let's
just watch this little few Clips let's
get context and then let's come back and
see what we can understand from this
because there's a big mistake we're
making a lot of Muslims are making
judgments on which I'm going to come to
inshallah having 10 sisters it's a
tumultuous roller coaster ride and when
you're Muslim American it's next level
my sisters and I share is completely
unbreakable all we really have in this
world is each other our parents fled as
refugees from Afghanistan in the early
80s we were raised in a very
conservative Muslim household the Elder
sisters are a little bit more
traditional the rest of sisters were
born in the U.S and we're the wolf pack
and we now look if they were just Afghan
and doing regular stuff I would say okay
it's kind of messed up people are seeing
Afghans but whatever I can ignore that
however they made it a point to flex the
religion of Islam in between all their
activities no I want you to see this all
right so this is the trailer just all
the sisters now watch this
boom nice your lucky mom is in here and
you have holes in your jeans nice nice
when you have a scene of all of them
praying together with the whole nikab
and then literally the next scene as
they
out at the club drinking I believe this
is classic media manipulation trying to
disintegrate the moral fabric of the
Middle Eastern youth in this country so
guys you saw that for yourself as you
can see these are people who outright
there's a big question mark on you know
a lot of things we can clearly say they
are outright evil doers they are calling
to evil they are dressing up in that way
this doesn't mean they are themselves
evil I want to make that Cliff they're
watching this video I'm not saying
you're evil uh please forgive me but
with Joshua was that power we have to be
very clear you know you guys are dressed
in that manner some of them even one of
them claims that she fell pregnant uh I
I I'm very careful this because it's a
major sin to uh to say that somebody's
an adulterer or like committed Xena we
don't know if it's marriage or not in
the car we don't know so there's no
elements but one thing about one that
was a following we have this perception
that let's suppose for God's sake here
these girls yes what they're doing is
evil and then they seem to be called out
it is evil and they're Muslims they
claim to Muslim they don't say that
they're not Muslims and they are Muslim
and they have one sister who is
practicing and there's some videos of
them all in hijab Etc praying I don't
know how true this is now can this be an
agenda it can because this is the same
organization that produces the Kim
Kardashians so whatever it may be the
point is the following people think that
just because some people do emo stuff be
it dressing up in mini skirts drinking
alcohol going clubbing selling drugs
whatever it may be that for some odd
reason that they cannot pray this is
nonsense I'm so sorry I don't know why
people always gonna say the opposite I
don't know if you he was I don't care
what evil they're doing it is Haram it's
wrong they're going to be judged however
you cannot come and say that oh but look
at them praying and the next minute
they're going to a club that's wrong but
you cannot say two wrongs make a right
oh you're coming don't pray you're
clubbing don't wear the hijab guys what
are you on about it's not our Dean
nowhere in our religion nowhere told you
to do that it tells the opposite the
prophet peace be upon himself if you
commit an evil deed replace it with a
good deed it's as simple as that and
Allah has said many times that these if
you do evil deed repent praying is
fundamental let me tell you something
and I'm not seeing these people it might
be that they have just Incorporated this
in there for the sake of it and their
Salah won't be accepted if they are are
putting this in the show on purpose and
they genuinely do not pray away the
hijab they us is a sign of hypocrisy and
Allah is not going to accept it every
intention is based on every deed is
based on his intention if they are doing
this to make the show more popular and
see that it's going to be rejected under
their judgment zero same as those
sisters who wear the hijab for fashion
reasons and on the day of judgment they
think they're going to be rewarded no
same for those brothers who may be um
doing whatever for whatever reason is on
the top of my head yeah and they were
doing it for the wrong reasons you're
not going to get accepted it's as simple
as that you put yourself through all
that hardship and you're not going to
get rewarded like um
he understood in this way
that made people come labor laboring
exhausted and they will enter the
Hellfire why because what they did was
not for Allah's sake but let's go with
okay they have this lifestyle clubbing
partying and I don't know some excuse
I'm not saying it like being pregnant
outside marriage I don't know I don't
know I don't know they're saying this
video it's probably alive but the point
is what that and then them go in and
praying their Salah you can't ever go at
them you can cannot conversate them oh
stop praying this is nonsense you cannot
do that this is Haram let them pray it
is that Allah says that will keep you
away from Evil Deeds eventually one day
that Salah will play a role so stop
discouraging people no matter how evil
they are I don't care if somebody's in
Hitman an assassin you still tell him
pray pray that's the right of Allah you
have to do that it is what makes you a
Muslim the prophet peace upon him said
so in a nutshell verse number one number
two finally Allah says in the Quran
my dear sisters you are busy with the
world DFS until you visit the graves and
no surely you're going to know my dear
sisters you're living this lifestyle and
this time Etc maybe you guys don't know
better if any of your sisters die you
guys are going to if you're gonna
remember
and for those things
Etc do you think on the day judgment a
group of females Muslims whoever they
are living this life partying dressing
up how you like to do whatever you like
do you think on your makayama the sister
who observe the hijab he protected
herself from Haram do you think that all
the stuff she did she's going to be on
the same level as them Allah says this
is an evil calculation what an evil
calculation you think that the righteous
one and the sinner is going to be same
never your reward is going to be Jannah
and in general my dear sister you're
going to have whatever you like whatever
you like gold you name it do not let
these kind of sisters sadly make you
feel as if I can't even I want him
because women like to be seen that's a
reality they like the attention that's
in their blood that's how they're
created so my dear sisters sacrifice her
for the sake of Allah do not lose and
don't be among those who are going to
gain the Dunya or should we say gain
something they're going to lose
so I just wanted to give this reminder
if you're a sister or brother who's
crabbing partying dressing up
inappropriate inappropriately whatever
it may be do not miss your Salah while
lie Karina Bay and hijab with you you're
wearing a mini skirt well like even if
you're going and win a bikini I'm
telling you well even if you're going to
win a bikini salad
I'm not going to go back to it you
shouldn't but if you're gonna go do not
miss
do not forget to support our Salah plus
project where we're teaching New Rivers
and born Muslims and how to praise Allah
step by step with the guided prayer
inshallah and helping them please
support our true pillar project getting
people to accept Islam and helping them
to learn Salah inshallah till next time